this is literally the worst weight loss
advice I have ever
[Music]
seen hey everyone I'm Abby sharp welcome
to aby's Kitchen today I'm pulling up
popular weight loss tips that I've seen
online and I'm going to tell you exactly
what I think The Good the Bad and the
Ugly okay so there's not a whole lot of
good but we'll get to that quick thank
you to Eric Williamson from unlocked
Fitness and Nutrition who assisted in
some of the research support on this I'm
going to be leaving a link to his team
below if you want to ignore all the
weight loss advice online and get the
help you actually need also a thank you
to my kids for getting me sick popping
in here to talk skincare for a second
because as a 35 almost 36y old skincare
has basically become my favorite hobby
or at least the only hobby I managed to
make time for in my day I am always on
the lookout for science fact products
that that actually work cuz I got really
sensitive skin and it doesn't always
play nice with every expensive cream on
the Shelf but proven skincare is really
unique they're the world's most
personalized skincare line that uses the
world's largest skincare database the
skin genome quiz and the way it works is
you do their three minute skin genome
quiz that analyzes 47 specific factors
so my skin concerns lifestyle humidity
water hardness UV Etc and then proven
award winning a die selects the best
ingredients for your skin the custom
skincare kit consists of a custom
cleanser custom day moisturizer with SPF
and the custom night cream it's
literally a unique formula made for you
based on your needs and once you've
taken the quiz you can either sign up
for a subscription or a one-time
purchase and honestly I'm kind of
shocked rarely do I like a product the
first time I try it I don't know usually
I'm kind of like a stick with what I
know kind of gal but I was thoroughly
impressed with the quality the text
texture and most importantly how well
it's worked for my skin normally my skin
is super dry and irritated this time of
year but it actually feels a lot more
soft and hydrated and my makeup is
sitting a lot nicer so if you want to
try proven yourself click the link in my
description box and use my promo code
Abby sharp to get your first
personalized proven system for $99 for
limited time this is actually a 50%
discount off of the retail price so
definitely get on it today all right
let's dive in super quickly before one
of you Falls victim to the very stupid
scary and downright dangerous advice
apologies in advance if I'm extra sassy
today you're stupid if you're fat this
is because it's so easy to lose weight
eating any type of nuts most people
would be surprised that nuts have a lot
of fats and calories in them they're not
a healthy food that you might think so
stop eating them oh Troy Troy Troy what
am I going to do with you first of all
one's body weight doesn't infer anything
about their intelligence I don't know
that shaming isn't a cute look second
they should be no shame in buying
yourself a bigger sized tank when it's
getting a little bit tight just saying
and third the fat free diet plan is so
'90s it hurts this is a really good
example of why we cannot just Define
food by its calories because unlike the
150 calories in let's say a chocolate
bar the 150 calories in an ounce of nuts
are defined by their hunger crushing
compounds and are super sting which is
really key for diet maintenance and
research consistently suggests that nut
consumption is not actually linked to
waking in fact research suggests that
those who consumed two or more portions
of nuts per week had 31% lower risk of
weight gain and even in studies when
nuts were added to the diet and total
calories were not controlled nut
consumption still didn't lead to weight
gain I talked about this in my video on
why a calorie doesn't equal a calorie
but Whole Foods like nuts are high in
fiber which are fuel for our good gut
bacteria so even if there's let's say
100 50 calories in nuts per ounce on
paper you're likely absorbing fewer than
that because your gut bacteria are just
like gobbling up the difference
definitely watch that whole video for
the full scoop because it is super
fascinating but bottom line nuts are a
great source of hunger crushing
compounds your gut bacteria love them
too and they can be a satiating and
satisfying part of a weight loss diet
next one of the easiest ways you can
lose weight with just changing one thing
about your diet this is Guy a look at
all the water in his belly now look at
guy B and look at all the water in his
belly and over time what that helps with
is puts you in a caloric deficit so one
of my top tips for all my clients is to
grab a half gallon jug and if you're
trying to diet instead of grabbing food
take a sip of water okay so this advice
has some Merit but when it's presented
like this it can definitely do more harm
than good so yes research suggests that
staying hydrated can potentially support
weight loss through a few different
important mechanisms one via
thermogenesis where drinking water
particularly cold water can transiently
increase energy expenditure by around
25% amounting to an extra 23 calories
burned per day is that going to move the
needle probably not a whole lot but I
guess all these little thermogenesis
boosts can help two as he's alluding to
here water can help to stretch the vagus
nerve and transiently reduce appetite
and chloric consumption one stud he
found that having two glasses of water
right before a meal reduced chloric
consumption by 22% another study found
that overweight and obese folks who
drank water before a meal lost 44% more
weight but these are all short-term
intervention studies where calories are
carefully manipulated and because the
appetite suppression is temporary and
limited by the short Transit time of
water in your stomach they don't
actually tell us a whole lot about what
happens when our body kind of figures
out that it's trying to be hacked so
when we look at long-term observational
data we see that those who drink the
most water consumed 9% fewer calories
and that greater water intake is
associated with lower risk of wak ging
but it's largely hypothesize that most
of this benefit is not because of the
thermogenesis or because of filling your
belly up with water it's because we're
replacing sugar sweetened beverages with
calorie-free water it's also important
to knowe that there is a physiological
difference between hunger and thirst
Sensations and it's through hacks like
this that we may actually further dull
our ability to tell the difference
difference one study found that Freel
living individuals respond incorrectly
to hunger and thirst 62% of the time and
trying to fill up your belly with water
whenever your body is literally hungry
for nutrition can just potentially
further this disconnect so no you
shouldn't just try to water down your
legitimate hunger this is super
disordered advice and it insinuates that
any and all calories are bad even if it
was not the intention of this Creator my
advice is a lot gentler and that is to
make sure you drink adequate water
throughout the day while maintaining
regular adequate meals in a modest
chloric deficit if you have a sudden
bodily discomfort come on and you are
truly unsure if you are hungry or you're
thirsty have a glass of water and wait a
few minutes if the craving for food
persists you are hungry and you should
absolutely honor that hunger not just
attempt to drown it out with more water
okay moving on hey Gary what's the top
concerns about weight loss weight loss
weight loss is a big topic and it's the
most misunderstood topic on the planet
today next to hydration if you want to
lose or regulate weight instead of
losing weight get to your natural weight
the best way to do that is remove the
stress from your body one to two times
per day it's stress at the end of it it
doesn't matter what you eat and it's
because of the adrenaline norepinephrine
and cortisol that you're firing in
stress hormones get rid of the stress
hormones do a fasal maneuver the stress
reset and the organ reset do that one to
two times per day your weight will start
start to stabilize right away I'm not
really sure what Gary's qualifications
are his bio says lifestyle artist and
citizen scientist which I'm pretty sure
is just a pretentious way to say lay
person but his website sells fascia
massage courses so naturally doing these
Maneuvers is apparently the key to
weight loss
nope Dy so as I discussed in more detail
in my video on cortisol right here both
extreme diets and exercise training
protocols can increase cortisol and
excess cortisol can increase belly fat
storage but the data suggests that this
doesn't seem to directly impair weight
loss if it does it's less because your
stress body is holding on to fat and
more because elevated cortisol makes you
crave higher calorie foods which makes
staying in a calorie deficit a lot more
difficult so yes of course we want to
try to manage our stress levels for many
different reasons weight manage
management just being one of them but at
the end of the day it still comes down
to creating a calorie deficit calories
in versus calories out is not perfect
but when it comes to Fat Loss it's still
a hell of a lot more reliable than
fascia massage next weight loss is 80%
diet and 20% exercise you ever heard
that yeah it's [__] it's 50/50 let's
say you're somebody who's doing nothing
but high-intensity cardio exercises that
style of training is going to lead you
under recovered and over stressed out
when those two things happen you are
going to have more Cravings more hunger
good [__] luck sticking to your
nutrition plan it makes it that much
harder for no other reason than the kind
of exercise that you're doing this is
why it's important to Marry both of them
nutrition and exercise so I agree with
some things that Eric says and others
are a little bit confused to start there
is no Universal golden number of how
much weight loss is exercise versus Diet
you just need to create a calorie
deficit and you can obviously do that in
a myriad of ways all diet all exercise
different permutations and combinations
of both Etc that said I will
respectfully disagree that generically
these two factors play out 50/50 and I'm
going to explain why for the vast
majority of people weight loss and
particularly fat loss mostly comes down
to diet since exercise alone is a lot
more susceptible to metabolic
adaptations like appetite increases and
or a reduction in neat exercise is
honestly great for a lot of things but
weight loss is not at the top of that
list as Canadian obesity doctor Yoni
friedhoff always says you can't outrun a
[Music]
fork well you can but it' be really hard
as you can see from this meta analysis
the contribution of diet alone to weight
loss is significantly greater than
exercise alone although obviously a diet
plus exercise regimen offers a
Competitive Edge as for hit training and
cortisol research has shown that intense
exercise for an hour and 15 minutes or
more results in a significant increase
in our cortisol levels which makes total
physiological sense cortisol's job is to
break down fat to make it available to
muscle when you need that energy so high
cortisol levels during or after a
workout is not necessarily a bad thing
it's actually a sign of a really intense
workout session in fact cortisol has a
stronger association with muscle gain
after strength workouts than
testosterone or growth hormone and when
cortisol is given like a drug it
actually can improve exercise
performance and while there definitely
are some cases where overe exercising
can cause daily levels of cortisol to
climb it's generally still more likely
to reduce cortisol levels over the
course of the day which actually means
fewer food cravings even during the most
intense training periods of of sprinters
their daily cortisol levels are lower on
average than those who do not exercise
now the exception here is when you
combine over exercising with severe
chloric restriction this is where we do
see a risk of elevated cortisol which
may impair fat loss among other health
concerns hence why I advocate for
fueling your body adequately when and if
you do exercise bottom line I agree that
exercise and diet do have to complement
one another in that if you exercise more
intensely you need to eat more and if
you are not exercising much you need to
eat a little less but for the average
individual it usually does not
contribute 50/50 in terms of importance
for weight loss next do you want to lose
weight fast so we doing a 7 Day liquid
Fest so the first thing that you can
have is protein shakes you can have no
more than six protein shakes within a
day most of us will only have three or
four then you can have broth the next
thing you can have is your tea and your
coffee oh and I'm going to make sure I
got my apple cider vinegar shot in and
not to mention get your water in stay
hydrated so Kesha let me quickly just
get this straight here you're suggesting
that we go for a week where the only
thing you're going to consume with any
kind of tangible amount of calories is
protein shakes and most of us will only
get to have three or four so if that's
the case you're suggesting we have
between 500 and 700 calories Max with
zero carbs and zero fat for a whole
weak and to add insult to injury you're
going to drink black coffee as a standin
for energy broth with nothing else in it
and apple cider vinegar which will most
certainly exacerbate any nausea you're
feeling from starvation I mean yeah if
you can maintain that level of torture
for seven days you can expect to lose
some weight I mean if you're not
constipated as but even a pure protein
diet will not save you from muscle
wasting on a starvation diet like this
this not to mention when you inevitably
binge on day eight you will gain the
weight back but more likely than not in
fact as I discussed in my video on
Macros for weight loss we know that
going from 10 to 15% of calories from
protein to 20 to 30% or around 1.8 G per
kilogram can significantly increase fat
loss by about three times I think a
daily protein shake is a really easy and
effective way to meet your protein needs
especially when trying to lose we weight
but if you're going to drag yourself
through 21 to 42 protein shakes in a
week you're going to burn out you're
going to get the ick and then you
potentially lost a really effective tool
for meeting your protein needs for
weight loss or weight management or
really anything else a shake a day is
great alongside other whole food sources
of protein alongside other
macronutrients and fiber and probably at
least three times more calories all
right that was a doozy and you guys know
there's so much more to this if you like
this video definitely give it a thumbs
up leave me a comment below if you have
any weight loss tips that you found
online that you would like me to unpack
there is a lot of them that I've come
across subscribe to the channel don't
forget to hit up my description for my
free Hunger crushing combo ebook and I
will see you next time on aby's kitchen
[Music]
bye